- Hey, what's up, Khan Academy students?
It's Tony Hawk.
I just want to wish you guys the best.
I know it is the strangest of times to be
in school, feeling isolated.
And just know we're
gonna get through this,
and it's gonna show your
determination, your perseverance,
making it through and
and doing well in school,
because it's hard.
My daughter's in the same boat,
and it's hard for her to stay
motivated, but you can do it.
You just gotta dig deep.
Believe in yourself.
And hope you guys can make it a great year
in spite of everything the
world has thrown at you.
All right?
And I'm pulling for you.
I'll see you on the other side of this.
Okay. Thanks, guys.